bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord est ce
que vous êtes inquiet face à aux robots
de la pandémie en tunisie au inquiet oui
mais on doit lutter averti peu inquiet
parce que on sait très bien que cette
guerre comme on dit dans les matchs de
fautes on a gagné la première mi temps
et on passe à la deuxième mi-temps pour
cet adversaire quand énigmatique et dont
on peut être inquiet averti pour
renforcer les règles barrière dont la
communauté
on est là pour l'ouverture des
frontières mais ont tout en respectant
les règles et directives des autorités
sanitaires pour lutter contre le non
lieu contre ce combi de 19 et s'agissant
des mesures prises par les autorités
tunisiennes pour lutter contre
l'épidémie on l'a dit les frontières qui
sont ouvertes depuis plus d'un mois pour
les voyageurs venus de pays classé vert
est ce que cette ouverture des
frontières
elle doit se poursuivre oui on avait en
quelque sorte on n'a pas le choix on
doit s'adapter on a passé la phase 2 de
fermeture totale
c'était cette pandémie mondiale on doit
s'adapter à ce virus
on doit prendre des précautions il ya
des directives des autorités sanitaires
dans tous les secteurs tourisme
entreprises et tout ça et chacun de nous
doit doit respecter ses règles ses des
troisièmes la règle et 3e le mâle
portent des masques
le métrage garder cette distanciation
physique est troisième mc lavage des
mains à la base du monde avec des mâts
et je suppose avec ses règles on peut
stopper 7,7
cette pandémie au mois à l'échelle
communautaire la commission de suivi de
lakovic 19 doit se réunir dès lundi
prochain
qu'en attendez-vous et quelle mesure
pourrait être décidée la gestion de
cette crise et laiteries spéciale elle
et elle est vraiment communautaire et
chaque et chaque jour il ya des
décisions spécifiques à chaque partie du
pays à ça que si on trouve 1 kloster
dans des commissions régionales
il ya des directives des décisions qu'on
peut prendre pour limiter limiter le
nombre de cas contaminés par le virus et
bien sûr chaque jour en attente du jour
des décisions etc on a laissé les
scientifiques de nous guider pour
appliquer ces directives ont le
bien-être du helmand quand vous sachiez
la tunisie est un pays touristique
on est ouvert pour certains pendant
l'été une nos compatriotes viennent pour
renforcer leurs vacances ils ont avec le
mariage avec les fêtes on doit se
déplacer mais tout en gardant les gestes
barrière à l'état d'esprit
la guerre continue contre ce virus mais
on est là pour le combattre avec le
respect des procédures
c'est vrai que c'est contre la liberté
de l'être humain mais on n'a pas jusqu'à
maintenant une arme pour lutter contre
7,7 anthony style que respecter les
directives des instances scientifiques
d'artistes annie terre actuellement par
exemple à l'aéroport de tunis carthage
et l'activation du laboratoire militaire
mobile à deux reprises carthage pour
faire au moins 300 analyse par jour pour
les différents secteurs opérant sur le
lieu de leurs portes jusqu'à rtas et la
porte est une des grandes portes
d'entrée en tunisie
vous l'avez dit la saison touristique
bat son plein en tunisie
ce n'est que le début c'est quand même
un port important de l'économie
tunisienne dans ce contexte là quand ça
va être difficile quand même de faire
respecter les gestes barrière dont vous
parlez
sur le terrain comment ça se passe vous
qui êtes en contact avec les malades
oui le mystère des détours hudon après
des directives avec les hôtelleries le
10 janvier les acteurs du tourisme et
dans chaque dans chaque secteur par
exemple dans les hôtels il ya des
directives à faire respecter
minimes et faire la distance et son
physique pour par exemple les hôtels en
france 50% de leur capacité d'accueil
pas plus pour respecter cette question
c'est son physique le port de masques
pour les accueille les hôtes est vrai il
doit les portes de masse qui allait le
gel lavage des mains et la
sensibilisation des sur soi médiatique
soit 'b to b' pour le personnel
à banias et bien sûr nos visiteurs nous
nous inviter son sens compréhensible
c'est un petit pain de mie donc on doit
respecter les directives de chaque
établissement et de chaque pays merci à
vous mohamed fadel oui je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin urgentiste engagés
dans la lutte contre la copie de 19 ha
en tunisie